we all knew this was coming even though
we weren't ready but there is no turning
back now Deku is crying as he realizes
that his Sensei almight is about to
sacrifice his own life to stop all for
one and even if all might succeeds in
that regard Deku still has the
overpowered and thoroughly insane
tomorrow shigaraki to deal with this was
a painful and heartbreaking chapter and
it's about to get a lot worse so let's
get into it you guys know this works if
you enjoy our mha content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and a comment right now for that
YouTube algorithm and if you want to
help us awaken the full power of our
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
here on the channel do me a big favor
and subscribe right now subscribing on
YouTube is completely free and we're so
close to 2 million so every single
subscription counts finally this video
will of course contain Boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter stain tried to help all
might defeat all for one but the villain
was able to deal with stain very quickly
honestly it was too quickly and after
all that waiting for stain to do
something this felt extremely
anticlimactic for me personally stain
basically got wrecked mere seconds after
getting involved in the fight and all
might also barely survived another
Fierce attack from All For One in fact
all might seemingly lost his right arm
he lost his ability to walk and at the
end of the chapter he was desperately
crawling towards the villain but to his
credit all might still refused to give
up and he still had a defined smile on
his face now we learned in the new
chapter that all might didn't really
lose his right arm it just looked like
that because of the angle of the panel
and where it was cut off so quick
correction for my previous video all
might still has both of his arms but he
is unable to stand on his own two legs
meanwhile all for one is now close
enough to the UA to use that gloop warp
Quirk to reach shigaraki things were
looking extremely bad for all might and
for everyone else as it seemed like all
for one was about to accomplish his goal
within mere seconds the latest chapter
begins by showing images of Shoto and
ochako lying unconscious and bloody but
thankfully still alive the police
confirmed that they've completed their
missions by neutralizing the major
villains Dobby and toga with toga's
defeat all those twice clones that were
infesting the floating UA finally
disappear and the heroes aboard the UA
including Momo and may hatsume are
extremely glad that the Clones
disappeared when they did the Clones
were adding a lot of extra weight to the
structure and this weight was
contributing to the structure losing
altitude now that all the Clones are
gone and the UA is a lot lighter May
believes that the structure should be
able to float again we then finally get
a real glimpse of the epic battle
between Deku and Shiga a battle that is
still raging near the UA where Deku is
trying to keep shigaraki from using his
Quirk deck was also doing his best to
keep shigaraki away from the UA building
and from his friends who are there but
Deku is about to have another major
problem as we saw at the end of the
previous chapter all for one is now
close enough to interfere with the
battle and he is planning to use that
gross sludgy warping Quirk known as
gloop warp to help bring shigaraki to
him he will then implant his copy of The
all-for-one Quirk factor into shigaraki
and he believes that this will be enough
to complete his takeover of his new
vessel with the original all-for-one
Quirk Factor alone shigaraki has been
able to resist all for one's control but
if he also receives the copy of the
Quirk factor that all for one has been
using up to this point his resistance
will be overwhelmed and he will submit
to all for one's control almight tries
to distract the villain by calling out
to him and telling him that he's still
alive but all for one refuses to let
himself be distracted again he is
determined to complete his plan before
he deals with all might once and for all
however when all for one tries to bring
shigaraki to him and the black sludge
begins to pour out of shikiraki's mouth
shigaraki forces his mouth closed and he
successfully resists being teleported to
all for one's location realizing that
shigaraki's willpower is simply too
strong to be manipulated so easily all
for one comes to the conclusion that he
will have to go to shigaraki instead but
he won't go alone all for one grabs the
injured all might by the leg and pulls
him upside down through the air as he
approaches the location of deku's battle
with shigaraki when shigaraki sees that
all for one has all might he mocks Deku
telling him that while he tries to save
almight shigaraki will just go and kill
everyone at UA Deku is practically
overwhelmed by this extremely difficult
situation he is exhausted he is at his
limit and he is terrified that his
mentor and Idol almight is about to die
right before his eyes and yet he can't
save him because he can't take his
attention off of shigaraki as almight's
Vestige begins to ominously fade away
Deku shouts all might as tears finally
begin to flow from his eyes he didn't
want to cry Almighty told him not to cry
anymore but Deku is Deku he can't help
it and as the tears begin to flow they
look to be like powered up tears that
are almost turning into some form of
energy as they leave deku's eyes there
it is boys and girls our theory that
Deku has had a secret crying Quirk all
along has finally been confirmed okay
not really but if you want to have some
fun down in the comments comment how a
crying Quirk could work and how it could
actually be overpowered Almighty then
begins to remember the precious moments
he had with Deku and how hard Deku
worked to learn learn to use one for all
and become a worthy successor to all
might when they first met Deku asked all
might if he could become a hero even
without a quirk and although he gave a
more dismissive answer then all might
now finally gives his full answer his
true answer of course you can become a
hero without a quirk he says to Deku
after all you always do your best and
never give up on your dream I've never
been able to give up on mine either my
dream of being the symbol of peace and
here almight is referring to both how
early on in his life he still tried to
be a hero and fight villains even before
he had a quirk and how now later in life
he is still trying to be a hero in fight
villains even after losing his Quirk all
might then proceeds to grab all for one
by the neck using his left arm the arm
that is still wearing a gauntlet-esque
support item which was presumably part
of his armor this is kind of weird
because the last time we saw all might
in the previous chapter we saw him
crawling and using his left arm for
support and in that panel his arm looked
bare there was no Gauntlet there I'm not
sure if this is a mistake or if
something happened in the meantime but
the point is that all might still has a
part of his armor left on his arm and he
is now using that arm to grip over one's
neck as all might looks directly at him
and smiles all for one remembers Nana
shimura and how his final battle against
her ultimately went it seems that just
before Nana died she told Gran Torino to
get all mine away from there and save
his life so Nana sacrificed her life for
her student so that he could live to
fight another day and unfortunately for
all of us all my fans it looks like he
is about to do something very similar
for Deku in fact in her final moments
Nana had said to all for one one day all
might is going to defeat you because
toshinori is even crazier than you then
in the present moment all night says to
all for one that if he dies one more
time and is forced to regenerate he will
rewind himself into a kindergartner this
means that all for one will be too small
to pose a threat to Deku and the others
so getting him to that point is the
hero's goal an instant later all might
Gauntlet explodes essentially it's
self-destruct presumably killing both
all might and all for one or at the very
least severely injuring both of them and
almost certainly destroying almight's
arm completely yes this could finally be
it this could be the death of all Might
almight's Final ultimate sacrifice for
Deku and the Next Generation so is this
finally it the end of all might I mean I
really don't know how you can even have
toshinori survive this unless we get
into some clone Shenanigans or something
along those lines if this explosion is
strong enough to basically end all for
one then it has to also be strong enough
to end a completely armorless and
quirkless all might the only armor that
can save all my now is some serious plot
armor so what do you guys say is all
might now dead like for good or is he
just gonna be really really injured and
if he is really injured will he actually
recover somehow like maybe Arie will
arrive and heal him on time or will he
just die in deku's arms in a dramatic
and heartbreaking way I have to say I
really liked how this chapter drew a
parallel between Nana's sacrifice to
save her successor all might and all
might sacrifice for his successor Deku
Nana said that toshinori would be the
one to defeat All For One and he already
did it twice and he may be about to do
it for the third time and for the final
time with this explosion but as Nana
said toshinori is crazier than all for
one so even though all for one would
never lay down his own life to defend
feet the hero all might is clearly
willing to make that ultimate sacrifice
so Nana's prediction about all might
being the one to defeat All For One did
end up being true but it might also come
at the cost of almight's life so if this
really is goodbye for all might how will
this affect the Raging battle between
Deku and shigaraki will Deku now get
angry and become even stronger or will
he be heartbroken and distracted which
will make him weaker with Dobby toga and
many other villains now defeated and
with all for one now seemingly about to
be defeated as well can shigaraki really
defeat Deku and all the remaining Heroes
alone or is this the beginning of the
end for the villains don't forget to
leave your feedback down in the comments
below if you're looking for an epic mha
video to watch next don't ignore my
video on what would happen if Deku
became the main villain of the story
link on screen and in the description if
you enjoy my content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
right now and if you want to help us hit
that insane 2 million subscriber Mark do
me a big favor and subscribe subscribing
on YouTube is of course completely free
and it helps me out a lot